Hãy bọn thời gian anh chai đi tụ, lây thân cường sống Trung với chiếc州 và có một con chung,
sự cô quan lại với trường đến đổi cường ra tay rất hạnh. Ngay mề bộ tháng một,
cường, bà mi bà tuổi, bị toàn nhân dân tính nó mạng sế sử về tụi giết người.
Tâm năm trước, anh cuộc gường, khi đó đã cưới loàn và có một con nhỏ,
phải chất hành hắn phạt bệ 5 tuổi về tụi giết người.
Thời ra này, cường ở nhà phát sinh tình cảm và sống Trung như một trong với chiếc州,
dù được mọi người càng anh.
2 người sâu đó ra ngoài thư phòng trọc, có một con chung, hệ bày tụi.
Tại trại ra, khi được người nhà cho biết mọi chuyện, anh chai cường đã yêu cầu vợ làm thủ tụi
li hôn như loàn không đồng ý.
Dưới thằng bốn năm ngoái, chỉ này hai tình trong chất hạnh sống án phạt lên chủ động
liên hệ bốn quay trở lại. Cường biết chuyển đến gàn tù, giữ địa thoại cùng
cân cứ cộng dân đến ăn chiếc sống dưới bỏ mình.
Tuy nhiên, loàn vẫn cứ định sọc đến ở Trung với trong, đông thời gọi địa yêu cầu cửa trả lại địa thoại,
dưới tờ. Cường đông ý, hệ gặp tại đoạn đường vắng cần mức nước dưới cạnh động.
Tại đây, cả hai sẻ ra cửa cái, anh ta dìm chỉ loàn xuống mức nước dưới lạnh theo chết chung.
Tuy nhiên, khi nạn nhân không còn phản khám, cường vì biết bơi, không thể tự chết đối đến đã bỏ chủnh khỏi hiện chương.
Tại thoại sang này, cường không nhiều, thưa nận hành vi, đi cao mong anh chai thả tử.
Anh của cường cũng dương, cho biết bản thân đã mất mắt quá nhiều, không yêu cầu bồi thường gì thêm,
chỉ mong hộ đông sẽ sử xem xác giám nhẹ hình phát trôi.
Hộ đông sẽ sử những định hành vi của bi cáo thề hiện sự xí đổi đạo đức vì phạm pháp lật,
tư đó toàn tuyên phát cường hai bên năm tụ.